et mortelle c'est le plus jeune immortel
sous la coupole le nouvel immortel
le commandant cousteau est devenue
immortelle depuis 1635
il y a des immortels en france
voilà une bonne question mais non pas l
ivresse immortel au delà du réel
et bien si il existait ils sont au
maximum 40 regroupées sous la coupole de
l'académie française
leur mission à ses immortels préserver
la pureté de la langue française à cause
que la voiture à ma soeur bon c'est pas
gagné je suis parfaitement d'accord sur
ce point
comment défendre les fondements de la
langue française avec un dictionnaire
par dix la 9e édition est en cours de
rédaction
9e édition seulement depuis 1635
car oui il faut du temps pour écrire un
dico d'académicien mais alors qui peut
devenir immortel pour être candidat il
faut avoir moins de 75 ans mais à part
ça pas de critère de nationalité ni de
profession il suffit d'obtenir la
majorité absolue des suffrages
mais bon il faut vous et un certain
amour à la langue française quand même
en 2013
un lycéen de 15 ans avait postulé
j'aimerais un jour à bochum 1-1 à
l'hiver à rameau d'olivier
il avait tout de même eu une voix sans
rancune pour le jeune homme a quitté
l'académie c'est un luxe que je me
refuse depuis sa création au xviie
siècle
l'institution est indépendante mais pas
irréprochable car pour la parité on
repassera
il a fallu attendre trois cent quarante
cinq ans pour que la première femme
revêtent la bid est immortel c'est pas
trop peur c'était en 1981 et c'est
l'écrivaine marguerite yourcenar
c'était une petite révolution pour
certains immortel resté bloqué à
l'époque de richelieu l'académie pendant
300 ans
n'est ce pas vécu ça mais qu'elle
pourrait encore vivre trois séances et a
pour certains gardiens du temple de la
langue française pour d'autres les
immortels traversent les siècles
mais ironie de l'histoire aucun immortel
n'a été centenaire
on nous aurait menti c'est pas parce que
nous n'allons pas mourir mais c'est
parce que nous avons précisément à
veiller à ce que notre langue ne meurent
pas on comprend mieux la réaction de la
première femme académicienne qu'est ce
que cette élection va changer dans votre
vie rien
[Musique]